¿Cómo superar una crisis? ¿Cómo puede
un país reinventarse, cambiar, transformarse?
Amigos de VisualPolitik, estas son dos preguntas
que nos habeis hecho bastante, tanto a traves
de los comentarios, aquí en YouTube, como
a traves de mensajes en Facebook y Twitter.
Pues bien, podemos que la economía normalmente
evoluciona mediante ciclos, esto es, a una
fase de crecimiento, más tarde o más temprano
siempre le sigue una crisis, y a esta nueva
crisis una nueva fase de crecimiento. Y así….
una y otra vez, suma y sigue.
Por ejemplo, desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
Estados Unidos ha atravesado 11 ciclos económicos
completos, estos es, con sus años de crecimiento
y sus años de crisis.
Sin embargo, amigos… esto no siempre es
tan sencillo… a veces… salir de una crisis
cuesta mucho, muchísimo. Tanto que, pueden
llegar a pasar décadas;
de tal forma que incluso un país rico y próspero
puede... dejar de serlo.
Porque no penséis que esto solo es algo que
afecta a los países emergentes, para nada.
Incluso los países más ricos pueden sufrir
este tipo de crisis tan profundas… generalmente
por razones políticas, mejor dicho, por malas
políticas.
Pero, eso sí, amigos, incluso de estas situaciones
se puede salir.
Aquí en VisualPoltitik lo hemos visto, por
ejemplo con el caso de Nueva Zelanda, que
tras pasar una durísima crisis consiguió
por completo darle la vuelta a la situación.
Pues bien… en este vídeo vamos a ver otro
ejemplo - por cierto, a un primo hermano de
Nueva Zelanda… Canadá.
Si, habéis escuchado bien.
¿Sabíais que Canadá pudo llegar a quebrar?
Pues atentos.
[Por cierto, al final del vídeo tenemos un
mensaje para todos vosotros]
Canadá es uno de los países más ricos,
más libres, más prósperos y con más calidad
de vida de todo el planeta.
La verdad, no importa el ranking que utilicemos:
Puede ser el IDH de Naciones Unidos, el ranking de corrupción de Transparencia Internacional,
el Índice de Libertad Humana del Instituto
Fraser o el índice legatum de prosperidad.
Da igual, en todos ellos, Canadá se sitúa siempre entre los primeros puestos..
Pero este vídeo no va de rankings… así
que… solo uno más.
(En el último ranking sobre los mejores países
elaborado por la revista US News y la Wharton School,
Canadá aparece como el segundo mejor país del mundo para vivir.
Sí, está claro, lo hemos visto ya en este
canal, Canadá, amigos es un país que está
de moda.
De hecho, en un pasado vídeo, en una de esas
encuestas que solemos poner al final, os preguntamos
si os gustaría vivir una temporada en este
país.
¿Y sabéis qué?
El 93%, ni más ni menos que el 93% respondisteis
que sí, que os encantaría vivir una temporada
en el país del curling, el sirope de arce
y la policía montada.
Sin embargo, amigos, las cosas en Canadá
no siempre han sido tan alegres.
Hubo un tiempo, en la década de los 60 y
especialmente en los 70 donde todo estuvo
a punto de venirse abajo.
EL DESASTRE
Durante años, Canadá fue un país muy parecido
a Estados Unidos, prácticamente un hermano gemelo.
(El gobierno era pequeño, el país estaba
muy descentralizado y los impuestos venían
a ser similares… claro, la idea era competir
para atraer inversiones y por aquel entonces,
también, por cierto, personas de fuera, inmigrantes).
Sin embargo, amigos, todo esto cambió a finales
de los años 60.
Por así decirlo, en esa época Canadá buscó
distanciarse de Estados Unidos y probar con
un nuevo modelo político y económico.
El gran artífice de toda esta “revolución”,
fue, Pierre Trudeau, sí, el padre del actual
Primer Ministro, Justin Trudeau.
[Claro que… las políticas del padre y del
hijo no son, ni mucho menos, exactamente las
mismas. Parece que Justin Trudeau tomó buena
nota]
Pero… no nos desviemos.
(El caso es que Trudeau padre, gobernó Canadá,
prácticamente de forma ininterrumpida, entre
1968 y 1984… Y lo cierto es que durante
estos 16 años en el poder el país cambió
mucho, pero que mucho.)
Veréis, Trudeau quiso implantar en Canadá
un nuevo modelo político que estuviese un
poco más lejos del capitalismo de Washington
y algo más cerca de la apuesta colectivista
del Moscú soviético.
(“Frente a la “mano invisible” de Adam
Smith, tiene que haber una mano visible de
políticos cuyo objetivo sea tener el tipo
de sociedad que es atenta y humana” - Pierre Trudeau,
De hecho, en política internacional una de
las cosas más conocidas de este personaje
fue su estrecha amistad con Fidel Castro.
En cualquier caso lo cierto es creo que podemos
decir que se le fue la mano:
(Trudeau padre subió mucho los impuestos,
multiplicó el gasto público, nacionalizó
empresas y como pensaba que todo eso del comercio
y la inversión internacional era malo…
por eso de la competencia… pues se dedicó
a poner barreras)
[¿barreras? ¿a quien me recuerda?]
El caso es que por si no fuera suficiente
también hizo que el Banco Central le diera
a la maquina de imprimir billetes para expandir
el crédito y financiar al gobierno.
[¿Os suena esta receta?]
Pues bien, el resultado de todo ello,
es que en pocos años, el déficit, el desempleo
y la inflación, pusieron contra las cuerdas
a todo el país.
Así que, cuando en 1984 Pierre Trudeau dejó
el poder, lo hizo con el nivel de popularidad
más bajo de un primer ministro canadiense
en décadas.
Tan solo 2 de cada 10 canadienses le continuaban
apoyando
Y en ese momento, los canadienses tuvieron
que tomar una decisión muy importante.
EL CAMBIO
En las elecciones de septiembre de 1984, los
conservadores obtuvieron una victoria aplastante.
El país parecía tener claro que no podía
seguir por el camino marcado por Trudeau.
Así que… dicho y hecho.
El nuevo Primer Ministro, Brian Mulroney quiso darle la vuelta a la situación
y empezó por estrechar lazos con el Presidente
Ronald Reagan. Una nueva era había comenzado..
Durante los siguientes 10 años el gobierno
conservador hizo bastantes cosas para mejorar
la economía de Canadá:
(bajó los impuestos, negoció el NAFTA, es
decir el acuerdo de libre comercio de Norteamérica
que une Canadá, Estados Unidos y México.
Y siguiendo los pasos de Margaret Thatcher
puso en marcha un ambicioso plan para privatizar
grandes empresas públicas, como por ejemplo
Air Canada o Petro-Canada.)
Sin embargo amigos, hubo una cosa que no hizo…
precisamente lo más dificil y lo más impopular:
controlar el gasto público.
En 1990, ojo, el estado suponía más de la
mitad de la economía, los impuestos seguían
siendo muy altos, el déficit público era
enorme y la deuda pública subía como la espuma.
Los conservadores habían tomado las medidas,
por así decirlo, más fáciles… pero a
la hora de la verdad no habían demostrado
mucho compromiso.
Así que en las elecciones 1993, el partido
liberal, el partido de izquierdas de Pierre
Trudeau volvió a ganar las elecciones,
esta vez, ahora sí prometiendo una auténtica revolución.
¿Sería capaz el partido de Pierre Trudeau
de salvar Canadá?
Dado los antecedentes, no me negareis que
era algo difícil, pero que muy dificil de
pensar.
Pero… amigos, esta ocasión fue diferente.
El nuevo gobierno quería cambiar por completo
y de una vez por todas el modelo de Canadá…
y no, ya no querían saber nada de Moscú
ni del modelo soviético.
La idea primordial era que la calidad de vida
no solo no está reñida como la economía,
sino que depende de ella.
Si se quería ganar calidad de vida tenían
que conseguir que Canadá tuviera una economía
fuerte.
Y eso es lo que hicieron, de la mano del Ministro
de Finanzas, Paul Martin, el auténtico impulsor
del cambio.
(Pues bien, en los primeros años, este gobierno
de izquierdas puso en marcha un fuerte recorte
del gasto público, acabaron con muchas cosas
innecesarias y se ajustaron el cinturón.
Por ejemplo redujeron con fuerza el gasto
militar y muchas subvenciones a empresas.)
Fijaos, en tan solo dos años, en términos
reales, el gasto cayó un 15%.
El gobierno, bajó ese principio que dice
que el Estado no tiene que dedicarse a cosas
que las empresas pueden hacer mejor, continuó
con el plan de privatizaciones… llegando
a privatizar los ferrocarriles e incluso el
sistema de gestión área.
[Y, no, no se han caído los aviones ni se
han producido más accidentes que en otros
sitios. Todo lo contrario, el sistema de gestión
aérea de Canadá es considerado uno de los
mejores del mundo.]
El caso es que en apenas 4 años, la situación
estaba controlado. El gobierno había pasado
de tener un enorme déficit a superávit.
Atentos a este gráfico.
Por supuesto estas medidas no fueron fáciles,
pero los canadienses parecían tener las cosas
muy clara, tanto que sorprendentemente en
las elecciones de 1997, el parto liberal,
el partido de izquierdas, volvió a ganarlas… prometiendo aun más austeridad
y también menos impuestos.
Según decían, amigos, su papel era proteger
y dar oportunidades a los más débiles, no
derrochar el dinero de todos.
Parece... sensato ¿No os parece?
Atentos a estas palabras de Paul Martin en
2003, haciendo un repaso a los 10 años en
el poder:
(“Tenemos que construir una economía del
siglo XXI en Canadá para los canadienses.
Hemos tenido éxito en los últimos 10 años
porque no nos desviamos de nuestro curso – presupuestos
equilibrados, una deuda pública decreciente,
impuestos más bajos. Debemos seguir en ese
curso. [...] Debemos ser un gobierno comprometido
con la rendición de cuentas. Un gobierno
que trata el dinero de los contribuyentes
como si fuera tu dinero.” Paul Martin.)
Amigos, toda esta revolución significó un
auténtico punto y a parte en la historia
de Canadá.
DESPEGUE VERTICAL
El cambio que vivió el país en los 80 y sobre
todo en los 90… permitió que la situación
cambiará por completo;
Canadá pasó de ser considerado por el Wall Street
Journal como un miembro honorario  “del tercer
mundo”, por sus problemas con la deuda pública...
a convertirse en el país de moda.
(El partido liberal no solo había solucionado
los problemas, sobre todo había cambiado
el modelo de país. En los siguientes años,
hasta hoy todas las opciones políticas han
apostado por este modelo de Canadá)
Ojo, Canadá no es un paraíso fiscal ni mucho
menos, pero por ejemplo han entendido que
a las empresas hay que cuidadoras y no castigarlas.
Fijaos:
Sí, así es. Si tenemos en cuenta todos los
impuestos que realmente pagan las empresas,
la situación de este país es muy, pero
que muy ventajosa.
De hecho, Canadá es uno de los pocos países
desarrollados que llevan casi 20 años
¡2 décadas! reduciendo cada poco tiempo los
impuestos para que lograr que el  país sea cada
vez más competitivo…
Atentos, a cómo han evolucionado, por ejemplo,
los impuestos a las empresas:
Y ojo, esta política ha favorecido sobre
todo a los más débiles.
Los salarios han crecido con fuerza, es uno
de los países que más inmigrantes recibe
y las tasas de empleo son muy altas.
Echemos un vistazo a este ejemplo:
(es muy común que en los países existan
instrumentos que permiten que los más ricos
puedan invertir sus fortunas pagando pocos
impuestos por los beneficios, siempre y cuando
sigan invirtiendo ese dinero.
Es lo que, por ejemplo, en España conocemos
como las SICAV.)
Pues bien, en Canadá no las han prohibido,
como proponen por aquí algunos político,
sino que han hecho algo mejor, mucho mejor:
han puesto en marcha un instrumento similar
para todo el mundo: las cuentas de ahorro
libres de impuestos.
Unas cuentas especiales que permiten aportar
casi 5.000$ por persona y año y que eximen
de impuestos a los beneficios que se obtengan
Es decir, si tienes beneficios por las inversiones
que realizas no tienes que tributar.
6 de cada 10 canadienses utilizan estas cuentas,
especialmente los que menos ingresos tienen.
No está mal ¿Verdad?
(Además, por si todo esto no fuera suficiente,
en los últimos años Canadá también se
ha convertido en un campeón mundial de las
libertades civiles, como ya hemos visto aquí
en VisualPolitik en algún que otro vídeo.)
Amigos, así es como Canadá
consiguió escapar de la mayor crisis de su
historia. Y por cierto, como también ocurrió
en Nueva Zelanda y en Australia, las reformas
fueron llevadas a cabo por partidos de izquierdas.
Esto no es una cuestión ni de izquierdas
ni de derechas, sino de comprender que una
economía fuerte, abierta al mundo y competitiva
es la mejor fórmula para mejorar la calidad
de vida de todos.
Pero, dicho esto, tenemos un mensaje
para todos vosotros.
En los últimos días hemos superado la barrera
mágica de los 500.000 suscriptores, ¡más de medio millón de personas!
Hay países más pequeños.
Bueno, bromas aparte, muchísimas gracias por estar semana tras semana con VisualPolitik.
Muchísimas gracias a esos más de 500.000 amigos que nos siguen y nos apoyan
todos los días. Vosotros hacéis que esto sea posible así que muchísimas gracias a todos, sois los mejores.
¡500.000 suscriptores! ¡Qué pasada! Si
nos lo hubiesen contado hace 2 años no nos
lo hubiésemos crecido. Muchas gracias a todos.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.